quelques quelques éléments en vrac sur
la partie obligation de travaux et
rénovation en fait brice qui est à ma
gauche a conduit pendant deux ans un
travail qui a été un travail de
concertation assez poussées avec à peu
près la totalité des acteurs qui sont
concernés par la partie technique donc
il y avait pas d'élus locaux parce que
c'est pas le sujet à ce moment là et
vous trouverez sur le site du shift
project un rapport qu qui est qui donc
c'est sûr les 2 c 3w de chypre allait
tout attaché point org vous trouverez le
rapport qui a été produit par ce groupe
de travail et qui précise ce qu'on a en
tête
comment est ce qu'on entend segmenter
les logements parce qu'il ya entre
l'individuel et le collectif là vous
avez tous penser collectivement fallait
quand même bonne partie des gens qui
sont individuelles ce qu'on fait avec
les belles et quelques immeubles
haussmanniens qui sont ceux auxquels les
décideurs pensent parce que c'est là
qu'ils habitent
etc etc donc tout ça vous le vous le
verrez dedans il ya également une
analyse économique sur la manière dont
cette affaire
ce lot ne flotte pas il ya également des
recommandations qui répondent pour
partie à ce qui a été dit sur le risque
juridique c'est à dire que le risque
juridique peu c'est peu s'évacuer très
largement par des obligations de moyens
qui sont embarqués dans la
réglementation des éléments qui sont mis
en oeuvre et donc il n'ya pas de
contrôle de conformité etc ce poste sur
lequel il pourrait y avoir des actions
etc etc
donc je je je vous renvoie au rapport
malheureusement on n'a pas le temps d'en
parler de manière détaillée ici mais ça
serait une bonne idée une question a été
posée sur l'allemagne l'allemagne je
vais vous donner de chiffres l'allemagne
avait investi 300 milliards d'euros en
ordre de grandeur pour passer de 4 22 %
d'électricité d'origine renouvelable
dans lequel la biomasse fait six ou sept
pour cent de mémoire les modes
intermittents strict c'est à dire
éoliens et photovoltaïques fonds 13% 7
pour l'éolien et 6 pour le pv et sur les
sept dernières années le contenu en co2
du kilowattheure globale et juste
électrique du kilowattheure énergétiques
utilisés en allemagne ne pas bouger
donc ils ont investi 300 milliards
d'euros dans un truc qui ne s'appelle
pas la transition décarbonés ça
s'appelle autre chose
grand bien leur fasse mais c'est ça n'a
rien à voir avec la question co2 et par
ailleurs ils ont mobilisé pas loin d'un
million d'hectares pour faire du maïs
fourrage pour mettre dans les
méthaniseurs ce qui pardonnez moi même
je tête vous choquer est une hérésie de
mon point de vue ils ont fait la même
connerie que les américains avec leurs
bioéthanol c'est exactement la même
exactement le même et on serait bien
inspiré de ne pas faire la même chose il
ya beaucoup mieux à faire avec le
méthane si on si on en produit à la
ferme à commencer par faire avancer les
tracteurs ça me paraît plus intelligent
que de faire de l'électricité tout à
l'heure une remarque a été faite sur le
fait qu'on était au sol alors moi j'ai
pas de contribuer comme j'ai des clients
savent et c'est aussi une espèce
capricieuse de temps en temps ça force à
voir un peu les pieds sur terre
après j'ai une règle de gestion à vos
propres cascades de schiste ne fait pas
vivre une règle de gestion à vous
proposer dans cette affaire de
transition qui est un truc un peu
transversale toutes mesures imaginées
doit être évaluée à l'aune du pétrole ou
du gaz que ça permet d'éviter d'importer
par rod capex investit donc on regarde
toute mesure qu'on envisage et on en
fait une évaluation économique ex ante
et sur combien j'ai vite d'importation
d'énergies fossiles a service rendu
identique par euros de capital investi
et vous allez vous rendre compte que les
honneurs électrique ces derniers trucs à
faire avec cet indicateur là par contre
le méthane pour mettre dans les
tracteurs arrivent probablement assez en
haut de la liste de priorités
l'isolation du bâtiment arrive aussi à
ses héros dc
donc si on prend cette règle de gestion
elle a un énorme avantage
c'est ce qui a été rappelé dans les
transparents qu'on vous a distribué cd
vous économiser un million d'euros
d'importations de pétrole et de gaz a
service rendu identique vous ne savez
pas où ils sont mais vous avez créé un
emploi
ça c'est une règle de trois très simple
dont vous ne savez pas où ils sont mais
vous avez créer 20 emplois
quand vous remplacer une énergie
domestique par une autre énergie
domestique à salaire identique dans les
filières vous allez créer zéro emploi
tous et tout ça découle d'une simple une
simple règle de trois après sans
s'aventurer dans le long débat très
intéressant de l'articulation entre
l'état l'europe et les collectivités
locales
j'aimerais juste heures une petite
remarque générique qui est que la
liberté va avec une obligation de
résultat et inversement c'est à dire que
plus les gens disent laissez moi libre
de faire comme je veux
et plus il devient légitime de leur dire
mais le résultat qui nous intéresse à ce
moment c'est ça et pas autre chose
voilà alors après on va pas ici résoudre
l'éternel débat planificateur libéraux
ou girondins jacobins mais juste
il ya quand même cette règle c'est du
bon sens pour moi qui est plus on
revendique de la liberté et puis on est
comptable du résultat c'est ce que vous
avez dans n'importe quel mode de
management n'importe quelle entreprise
si vous obliger les gens à faire ils
sont moins comptable du résultat que si
vous leur dites c'est ça qui m'intéresse
et démerdez vous et enfin je vais
revenir pour finir sur encore une fois
quelque chose de très générique qui a
été évoquée souvent qui est la question
du manque de moyens il est absolument
évident pour moi je lui ai dit tout à
l'heure que le contexte économique je ne
vois pas de raison à cause de sa
dépendance à l'énergie qu'ils
s'améliorent au sens où tu paies idées
au sens du pib je ne vois pas de raison
qu'il s'améliore je vois même une
excellente raison pour que ça continue à
aller dans l'autre sens ce qui veut dire
que tant qu'il ya pas des plans pour
l'avenir qui flotte un peu c'est les
extrêmes que vous verrez monte parce que
les promesses irréalistes renforcent les
extrêmes
d'accord c'est çà çà çà çà la sanction
et c'est ça qu'on est en train de voir
partout en europe dès à présent donc
dire la vérité aux gens je pense que
c'est utile aujourd'hui c'est pas juste
un luxe je pense que c'est absolument
indispensable
et quand on est dans un contexte de
ressources contrainte ça veut dire qu'on
est obligés de choisir
ça veut dire qu'on aura plus fromage et
dessert et la liberté de faire ce qu'on
veut partout et tout le temps il va
nécessairement falloir choisir
et évidemment si on n'associe pas la
population aux choix et la
hiérarchisation les choses se passent
moins bien mais par contre c'est pas
parce qu'on associe la population aux
choix que les revendications de chacun
doivent être empilées les unes sur les
autres pour finir par arriver un truc
mon pense qu'on va comporter tout le
monde
malheureusement ça n'est plus possible
ça n'est plus possible parce que on est
en train de découvrir que le monde est
finie pour reprendre une citation qu'il
ya quelques décennies maintenant donc
j'insiste sur le fait et ça va avec
marek de gestion j'insiste sur le fait
que toute mesure aujourd'hui doit être
pensée non pas un moyen croissant mais
plutôt à moyen des croissants et que la
seule manière d'y échapper
j'en reviens c'est de flécher de
l'endettement contre hambourg sera
peut-être pas faut se le dire vers des
investissements qui sont absolument
indispensables pour que le p -o
sa capacité à fonctionner avec de moins
en moins d'énergies fossiles alors ces
investissements là on peut les créer et
on peut les flécher c'est pas
nécessairement du budget général
j'insiste c'est pas né celui de général
mais on peut les créer et on peut les
flécher et surtout on n'est pas obligé
de les faire porter uniquement par les
collectivités les ménages et les
entreprises peuvent emporter une partie
aussi par contre ce qu'on peut pas leur
demander c'est tout portait à la fois en
quantité croissante
c'est juste un truc qu'on pourra pas
leur demander ça marche pas voilà
quelques remarques finales et pour ceux
que ça intéresse on a plein de
documentation à leurs données sur un
certain nombre de choses qui ont été
évoquées ce matin